ja willkommen zur digitalen
ersatzsitzung des
konsequentialismus-italismus-seminars
heute wollen wir noch mal Rückblick
geben John rolls
und sein Verhältnis zum
Utilitarismus
wir ziehen uns dabei auf seinen
Hauptwerk Titel eine Theorie
Gerechtigkeit das ist 1971 zum ersten
Mal erschienen
die deutschen Übersetzung wenn man ein
paar Leitfragen aus welcher Perspektive
betrachtet schon digitalismus bei
Cedric zum Beispiel
welche Kritikpunkte führt falls
irgendwie durch die gitarismus an
das sind so zwei Fragen in der ersten
Hälfte des Seminars haben wir klassische
Theorien und digitalismus in der zweiten
wollen wir Kritiken daran diskutieren ja
jetzt sagt er
das Entscheidende bei uns
digitalistischen
gerechtigkeitsvorstellung ist das ist
keine Rolle spielt wie die Summe der
Befriedigung über die einzelnen Menschen
verteilt ist wir hatten schon gesehen
der gitarismus
Bedarf des Begriffs der Gerechtigkeit
jetzt ist aber die Frage die wie können
wir am besten Gerechtigkeit herstellen
John rolls hat ja ein Buch geschrieben
das hatte ich gesagt eine Theorie
Gerechtigkeit das heißt der betrachtet
aus
gerechtigkeitstheoretischer Perspektive
den klassischen klitorismus
er sagt jetzt dass nach dem klassischen
muss an sich keine Verteilung der
Befriedigung besser ist als eine andere
so dass nur die gleichmäßige vorzuziehen
ist denn sonst keine Unterscheidung
möglich ist jetzt macht hier rounds ein
Problem aufmerksam er sagt es gibt im
Prinzip keinen Grund warum größere
Vorteile einiger nicht geringere
Nachteile andere aufwiegen sollten oder
noch wichtiger warum die Verletzung der
Freiheit einiger weniger nicht durch das
größere wohl viele andere gut gemacht
werden könnte das also das Problem ist
das Gerechtigkeit
nach diesem klassischen klitorismus auf
eine ziemlich ungerechte Weise zustande
kommen kann
diese gleichmäßige Verteilung die
rolls fordert die sowas wie eine
Verletzung einzelner ausschließt
die ist sagt er nach dem motivtarismus
nicht möglich diese strenge will er
nicht als ein Grundsatz der Moral
annehmen diese gleichmäßig Verteilung
die sowas verhindert
jetzt kommen wir auf Richard Brand zu
sprechen
der hat jetzt den Begriff des Regeln und
die gitarismus geprägt in derselben Zeit
wie auch turnals sein theoretische
Gerechtigkeit entwickelt hat
wir haben auch hier eine geleitwagen
die
modifiziertalismus
wie verhält sich Brands Regel unter die
Tourismus zu der autologischen
Zitat er sagt der Gute gitarismus
dass die moralischen Prädikate eines
Handelns zumindestens seine Objektiv
Richtigkeit oder Falschheit und
gelegentlich auch seine loben zu der
Tages werden Eigenschaften und diese
Hinsicht direkt oder indirekte
Funktionen verfolgen für das Wohlergehen
Empfinden der Lebewesen und nichts
anderes sind
weil es geht um das Wohlergehen von
Lebewesen wir hatten das gesehen am
Beispiel von Peter Singer da mache ich
auch oben rechts an Link dazu ein
muss also nach dem moditarismus
lediglich die Folgen kennen und
bestimmte Dinge für das
Wohlergehen die die bestimmte Dinge für
das Wohlergehen haben
jetzt möchte er eine besondere Form von
uns die Tourismus betrachten und die
nennt er
regel-tarismus und die setzt er dem
handlungs- und literismus gegeben also
die Theorien die wir bisher behandelt
haben das klassischen territarismus sind
handlungs-
es geht nach dieser klassischen Theorie
darum dass eine Handlung bessere Folgen
hervorbringen soll
jetzt kritisiert ihren Brand dass der
handlungsrozialismus eine atomistische
Theorie sein Atomismus heißt es geht um
das einzelne es geht um die einzelnen
Handlungen die bewertet werden Blick auf
die Folgen
die Richtigkeit an Einzelhandel wird
durch ihre Folgen für die Welt bestimmt
nicht weit genug wir müssen weitergehen
und jetzt sagte der Regel und die
literismus dagegen vertritt die Ansicht
dass die Richtigkeit an Behandlung nicht
durch ihren relativen nutzen bestimmt
wird sondern durch den Nutzen der daraus
resultiert dass man eine relevante
moralische Regel hat oder daraus dass
die meisten oder alle zu einer
bestimmten Klasse von Handlung
gehörenden Handlung ausgeführt werden
also
es geht zwar nicht
um den Nutzen einer
individualistischen Handlung
sondern um die Frage
welche moralische Regel
diese Handlung und ihren Nutzen zugrunde
lag
hier sieht man dass der digitalismus
etwas abweicht vom klassischen
handlungs- weil er Prinzipien
berücksichtigt die nicht allein durch
den nutzen Sie nutzen Maximierung
eingeholt werden können
als eine Modifikation des handlungs-
der Regel unter gitarismus sagte jetzt
kann man in zwei Hauptgruppen einteilen
je nachdem ob man die Richtigkeit einer
besonderen Handlung zu einer Funktion
von einem gewissen Sinn idealen Regeln
oder von geltenden und anerkannten
Regeln einer Gesellschaft machen es gibt
also eine idealistische Form von
regel-tarismus und eine
empirische oder
soziologische oder
gesellschaftstheoretische Theorie
er möchte sich jetzt der zweiten Form
besonders zu wenden nach dem letzten
genannten Typ der Theorie
gesellschaftstheoretischen
regiotikarismus werden die moralischen
Pflichten oder Verpflichtung eines
Menschen einer bestimmten Situation mit
einigen Ausnahmen nur durch die
moralischen Regeln
Institutionen oder Handlungsweisen
bestimmt die der Gesellschaft vorrangig
sind
und nicht durch Überlegung welche Regeln
in der Gesellschaft an Idealisten werden
er stellt sich freiwillig die Frage auf
welcher Basis nach welchem Prinzip wird
diese Regeln entwickeln nachdem sich die
Gesellschaft ausrichtet das ist eine
weitere Frage die man noch diskutieren
muss ja vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit und bis zum nächsten
Sitzung im präsent